and crush me at him oh that's I meant
about yesterday me my dad won that hike
I usually run it but I walked it he went
six miles you went with me jog yeah yeah
but where we hike at is where Kanye does
his weird service and so we tried going
through this one way there's security
everywhere and my you know my dad's
always like what the [ __ ] is this and
like we might have to cut this way it
took me longer juice no we're not
cutting anything we're gonna go through
here so the security is okay you can't
come through my dad's like the [ __ ] we
can path does this way our car is that
way the kensic all right sir and so
we're going that way but there's
security everywhere
he does like this weird service I
stacked the coats or what looks like a
[ __ ] cult all his people are in like
just normal people and white like Clint
and they all have [ __ ] Yeezys on it's
great well that's that that's that
old-school Baptist [ __ ] where you you
all dress in white and then you get
baptized there might be a baptism no no
no no I'm telling you I see it all the
time
what's he [ __ ] man just having fun
that go that picked right there what's
wrong this one the one down wait right
there
that's right hike that's him that's him
and his do you know that was him I saw
that on Instagram then I thought that
was you sites la two men and security
rude and there's like Bentley's and
[ __ ] Rolls Royces and and so it's
just a usik thing or what is oh it's a
Sunday Gospel Church okay there is a
diet I've been to Sunday Gospel Church
in Harlem there's a pastor there yeah
I've been I've been not only have I been
to Sunday Gospel Church in Harlem I've
also been to a funeral of my friend's
mom in Harlem because she grew up in
Harlem and he did too no I get that did
a musician get on and create be 100% a
musician guy I heard the Deacon
everybody this singing was on believe it
goes now ol MA it wasn't a sad woman so
I don't want to see a long long faces in
here I want to see some I want to see
some music and I want to celebrate her
life and they got into some singing that
I was just like this is the greatest
thing I've ever spoken seen in my life
it was the greatest thing there you got
to come down that's how the music came
from that's where a lot of like his
I don't know how suit like DMX came to
this well he's a preacher but they all a
lot of them learn how to sing in the
church Whitney Houston learn how to sing
in the church Katy Perry learns thing in
the church showed it [ __ ] Aretha
Franklin all jacks how to sing the list
goes on and on yeah so you know I'm
joining the black church it does look
fun I said it's weird there's like
security and then all these kanye west
he's outside
oh dude outside on top of the mountain
where everyone's hiking kind of like
that cuz he's preaching from the sermon
he's preaching these from the
mountaintop sermon on out yeah you don't
know [ __ ] about Christian it's a little
strange going to hell anyway people
thought yeah there are white people
there okay I know I was worried do I put
my shirt on it's a hike with my shirt
off was gon put my shirt on so I don't
scare everybody yeah just a giant guy
with tats yeah B mm-hmm yeah this this
Gracie tattoo looks a little a little
bit like you see a giant a on a guy can
what's going on he in an order there it
is yeah I play that let me see it
hopefully see me and my pop in the
background
[Music]
that's really an excuse to jam it's so
cool though is it yeah I think so all
that lingo is learning how to fit be
musicians why find it subversive
cult-like very cult-like you know it's
weird to me is like the grown people in
the Yeezys all right yeah that's awesome
that's so good it's like mmm
that wasn't Kanye West what you'd be
saying that least er outside and doing
some positive though yeah there you go
so cute though
well mmm cuz I'm doing in that church
today we can join how can I get in show
up in a white robe Easy's so most people
look like this yeah that's never
happening I'm never getting and I'm
never putting that stuff well then you
can't be in it yeah well that's how lay
you see the picture I post my Papa
that's the shot right there
it's very strange right yeah the weird
thing Oh when you see my back I pull
myself up like a champ like 30 times
fast while talking to you why wouldn't I
give that to you as it's a gif it's a
gift it's a gift